the world's 2.2 billion Christians
celebrate Easter this weekend there are
some who find comfort and meaning in
this symbol the Virgin of Guadalupe is a
representation of Mary that dates back
centuries images of this popular Madonna
can be seen on walls candles even human
skin while what it represents is
spreading there are some who are making
sure these images remain seen
in Los Angeles photographer Oscar
Rodriguez Zapata focuses his camera as
often as he can on a mother why the
Virgin Mary I think it's just I mean for
me personally I think it's just you know
a level mother and I think the love of
my is very important it's the thing is
the most beautiful thing you could be
able to receive in this world I know a
mother protects mother loves why not
have the mother of uh of Jesus
protecting none of us our community his
business the mother he photographs is
known as Our Lady of Guadalupe and she's
adorned in murals on the sides of Los
Angeles buildings
the image immigrated from Mexico where
some 20 million people come from all
over the world every year to a basilica
on the hillside where Our Lady of
Guadalupe appeared in 1531 to an
indigenous man named Juan Diego this
particular image of our lady was
imprinted on a cloak Juan Diego is said
to have worn and replicated ever since
but you're taking me to one that's just
literally a couple of blocks away that
is correct yes here in San Los Angeles
you know there's plenty of murals of the
Virgin Mary I've been trying to document
them as much as I can but it's a lot of
work so how many have you documented and
where are they I think documented about
500 or so but so far how many shared
about 300 on my social media his
Instagram page shows his vast collection
of his photographs taken in all kinds of
places what's the business here
repair service yeah it seems like it's a
computer uh phone repair but it just
seems like there's something about
having the Virgin Mary here there
there's it seems like a way to protect
the store yeah it's uh for the majority
of times
um you know to protect the their
business to protect them and to protect
the people around them you know the
neighborhood in the community the
neighborhood Our Lady of Guadalupe
protects has expanded greatly it's very
interesting because I live uh in
Virginia and people don't typically
associate
Virginia or the University of Virginia
as a place where you would happen Upon
Our Lady of Guadalupe in your daily life
but whether I am you know buying a taco
from a taco truck or I'm at an art
gallery in downtown Charlottesville I'm
seeing Our Lady of Guadalupe everywhere
at the University of Virginia religious
studies Professor Nicole Flores has
written about the Virgin of Guadalupe as
a growing phenomenon Crossing cultural
law lines Her Image while it has a
particular resonance in the southwestern
United States Her Image is really very
prevalent in other parts of the United
States which is partially because
Mexicans and Mexican Americans of course
reside in every part of the United
States but it's also due to this General
attraction and how compelling Her Image
is to people even if they are not
Mexican or Mexican-American
but Los Angeles's Embrace of Our Lady of
Guadalupe is particularly revered at the
cathedral downtown there is a piece of
Juan Diego's cloak a special Shrine and
all kinds of artifacts in the gift shop
and on the street Artisan Fabian Deborah
has been maintaining his painting for
two decades it's symbolic like when the
mothers come and put a nice set of
flowers then as an artist I must do the
same and keep those flowers vibrant he
is just one of the now hundreds of
artists inspired to keep Our Lady of
Guadalupe vibrant and accessible
another artist known as ronic donated
this one specifically for children but
murals on outdoor walls are vulnerable
which is why photographer Rodriguez
Zapata is on a hunt to find and
photograph them how did you find this
one you know I passed through this
neighborhood here for uh seven years in
this gate here three years ago collapsed
it looks like there was a fire yeah
there was a fire the gate collapsed so
um I was able to find this Virgin Mary
here as mural to him treasuring them is
the best way to protect the mother who
so many believe protects them
you know I lived right in the
neighborhood and never really noticed
them before but when you know that
they're there now they're everywhere
they start popping up all over and I
drove miles and miles and miles and they
just were all over South Los Angeles
they're beautiful I asked the question
during the piece of whether you're
legally allowed to do it and you you
made the interesting point that a lot of
these schools commissioned them well
schools uh you know businesses any
anybody can ask an artist to you know
put one on their on their grocery store
yeah some probably may not be but but
folks do appreciate their vibrant and
they are